>> Alright Michael, what's the answer?
>> Alright so of those others, well C
is pretty good, because it does separate the
pluses from the minuses. We, we even liked it so much we used it in round two.
>> Mh-hm.
>> But it doesn't as good to me as A, because A actually does a good
job of separating the very, the more heavily
weighted points. So I would, I would say A.
>> So in fact that is what our little learning system shows.
It shows A. Now, through the trick of animation, I
leave you with A. And that is exactly the right
answer. By the way, Michael, if you look at these
three hypothesis and their weights, you end up with something kind
of interesting. So if you look at this third hypothesis
that's chosen here, turns out they have a very low
error, you'll notice that the errors are going down over
time, by the way, of 0.14. And it has a much
higher alpha of 0.92. Now if you look at these weights and you add them up, you
end up with a cute little combination. So,
let me draw that for you. Okay Michael, so
I cleaned up a little bit so that you could see it. If you take each of
the three hypothesis that we produced, and you weight
them accordingly, you end up with the bottom figure.
>> No way.
>> Absolutely.
>> That's. Kind of awesome. So what you're saying
is that, even though we were only using half planes,
or, or axis-aligned semi planes, for all the weak learners, that
at the end of the day it actually kind of bent
the line around and captured the positive and negative examples perfectly.
>> Right. Does that remind you of
anything else we've talked about in the past?
>> Sh. Everything. Nothing. No, I dunno, I mean so with,
with decision trees you can make the shapes like that, and
>> That's true.
>> And the fact that we're doing a weighted
combination of things reminds me of the neural net.
>> Yeah. And it should remind you of one other thing.
>> I'm imagining that you want me to say
nearest neighbors, but I can't quite make the connection.
>> Well, you recall in our discussion with nearest neighbors,
when we did weighted nearest neighbor. In particular we did weighted
linear regression, we were able to take a simple hypothesis,
add it together in order to get a more complicated hypothesis.
>> That's true, because it's local.
>> Right, exactly because it's local, and
this is a general feature of Ensemble methods that if you try to look
at just some particular hypothesis class. Let's
just call it H, because you're doing weighted
averages over hypotheses drawn from that hypothesis
class. This hypothesis class is almost all
low, is at least as complicated as
this hypothesis class and often is more complicated.
So you're able to be more expressive, even though you're
using simple hypotheses, because you're combining them in some way.
>> I'm not surprised that you can combine simple things to get
complicated things. But I am surprised that you can combine them just
with sums. And get complicated things because sums often act very, you
know, sort of, friendly. Right it's
a linear combination not a nonlinear combination.
>> Actually, Michael part of the reason you get something
nonlinear here is because you're passing it through a non-linearity
at the end.
>> The sine.
>> Yea, that's a good thing, we should, we should ponder that.